[Music]
all right let's go to
ann and peter pan and in houston texas
what's up anne
hey how are you just i mean incredible i
i i'm not i'm not incredible things are
fine i kind of overstated that a bit i'm
trying not to speak in hyperbole too
much but i do so i'm great how about you
you'll live in the dream oh
which is latin for not great at all at
all
oh man so what's up
so um
i don't know how to even ask this but i
think
the best way the best way is just
like
no
no whitewash in it no trying to like
power wash it just just ask it it's
awful and weird as whatever it's gonna
be you're about to ask just go for it
i think i'm broken i don't really love
my newest child okay
um hold on hold on exhale have you said
that out loud before
uh yeah i said that to my husband okay
am i the first person not your husband
that you said that too
i know i have friends too
so no i tell everybody i i have a shirt
that's not true
i don't
but i do i've got a couple girlfriends
and you know my husband but yeah it's um
you're not broken
i don't even know what you're about to
add what but say you're not okay okay
cool
yeah you may be
like really deranged and mean but i'm
totally kidding you're not broken okay
so you don't love your newest kid right
now tell me more about that
so um
we have three um
all
have been um
adopted okay
um
and
um our first two we
um we went
domestic or their birth moms chose us
you know we had
um i had them as infants and this new uh
little guy he came to us
um at almost three years old um
and
his grandparents asked us to adopt him
and
um
we've yeah it's i'm
doing all the things that i'm supposed
to do you know like the the really long
hot
in the skin
morning and as soon as i pick him up
from uh from child care and at night
and
like i just
you know i
it's it's like a chore i it's
um playing with him as a tour and
um what what i don't know why is it a
chore what is it is is it something is
he different is he have attitude
problems is he struggling like what or
is it just no we're not connecting
i think we're just not connecting he's a
he's a pleasant child he um
his
his uh grandparents were raising him
very differently than we do he was very
addicted to scream um
he um
he didn't really have much
he struggled with speech
i think because he wasn't really spoken
to a lot um
so but but he's a charming child like
he's he's a sweet kid um
he there's he's i know that with
with trauma like he's experienced just
being taken from one child uh
you know
one parent to another um i know that
that's very traumatic and i kind of
expected more behaviors
but we he he kind of is doing really
well
sometimes sometimes kids act really well
as a trauma response
yeah they know that well he threw a lot
of tantrums at the beginning but he's
come out of that so um
this feeling of dislike
um
it often comes from something outside of
our picture of the way we thought things
were gonna be
yeah so what did you think was gonna be
different
than what actually is just give me two
or three of them
you know i
i had very little expectation
um about this you know um
i think i struggled with that with my
first child because i i mean i felt like
the babysitter for
months you know um
but
um but i've i didn't have a lot of
expectations we've always wanted to have
um
you know something of a large family not
you know adoption is expensive and we're
not
you know we don't
want 10 but
um it kind of was this ideal situation
where our children would be close in
aids and you know a little guy would get
a little you know actually an older
brother and
so let me ask you this
i've had i i've had several pictures in
my life about how i wanted things to
work out
yeah and then as i've gotten really
close to that picture
it's it's changed and that change i
don't want that anymore or i get it and
i wish i didn't have it whatever it has
to it happens to be
and it's
incredibly disorienting because i've
spent however many years working towards
saving towards trying to achieve towards
and suddenly i get it
and it's not what i thought
but here i am
and
you can you will let me just say this
this way you will
because you're i can tell by the things
you're you're trying right you are
leaning into this discomfort
i have no question in my mind that
you'll develop an extraordinary
relationship with this kid
the bigger concern i have is you're
gonna begin to regret your life
and i want you to make peace with that
is it that we should have stopped it too
i've heard that from people with three
and four kids our live like if we had to
do it over i love little timmy and
little susie but we just stopped it too
financially right or
um
any fill in the blank any number of
things right you can go back and play
that what if game in the variable game
all day long but what i want you to do
is to land in the middle of your life
that you're living right now
has this um young man
this little boy has he altered your
marriage has he altered your free time
your financial life like tell me where
there's been a disruption in things
well i
i mean and if there's not it's not
that's great
it's more with my other
my other son you know like
i've always been super charmed by my
children and um
i i'm just playing
like
referee
all the time with and it's just it's not
fun to be around my kids anymore there
you go there you go so you see what i'm
saying the actual problem is with the
life not with the kids
yeah
um often in my marriage when i've gotten
really frustrated and i don't think i
like my wife anymore what i really don't
like is i still love her but i don't
like her and she'll tell you there's
seasons when she just doesn't like me um
she still loves me
but it's almost always the life we've
created for ourselves that we're living
in
is leading to
me too does that make sense here i'm
saying
so yeah some of the hard realities that
happen my friend says there's a huge
shift i only have two kids so i'm
speaking out over my skis here but
there's a shift that happens that nobody
tells you about
when you go from man-to-man to zone
there's a difference when you have two
kids and suddenly you go to three and
i've also heard that once you get four
five and six and 11 nobody cares right
there everything's fine once you make
that other shift into that new gear but
there's something
um disorienting and transformational
about having going from two to three
just hard everything just gets harder
the the
getting kids in and out of car seats
just to go to the freaking store right
or just i just need to go to the
bathroom without another human staring
at me all these things uh nate you've
got four am i right is it yes okay so
nate is in there running the youtube
cameras he's just i see him nodding in
there over and over that there's a shift
um james has 117 kids out on the prairie
and
was it similar
like going from two to three and two to
four
yeah it was a huge change going from two
to three that was a big leap okay
between the two so here's what i want
you to to
look at anne this and this could be a
really fun thing how's your husband by
the way
he
is
he feels a lot of anger towards the
grandparent okay
so are they his grandparents
no
are they your grandparents
no it's it we're not related okay okay
yeah why do you have anger towards your
grandparents just um
they keep telling us things like a
little at a time like his mother is
bipolar and
oh he she was also taking this drug when
she was pregnant and
it's like they
wanted us to take him because they they
couldn't anymore
um i think like i said he's i think they
did the best they could i but they're
very lazy and um he just had a screen in
front of him all the time and
yes we kind of see the
behavior
that
came from that especially at the
beginning and
so let me tell you this
yeah um and i'd love to talk to him
someday your husband
this new baby this new little boy you
brought home is not broken
yeah i know okay
um he's not like you bought a used car
and suddenly the dealer calls you once a
week it's like oh by the way the fan
belt doesn't work
right
so
listen any any
one ounce of energy
spent hating grandparents being pissed
off at grandparents is a com is a total
utter waste of your time in life
yeah they're done i would remove them
from our life
oh we can't do that though
we're open adoption okay
i would marginalize as much as humanly
possible
yeah we we started doing that we first
invited them to our house and we saw how
nope he reacted and it just so he's been
meeting that's right so no but you know
that adoption professionals tell you
like the more that they have
contact biological family the better and
i know i know but hold on not in abusive
situations
nobody wasn't abused he was just like
not
they were just lazy you know that's
abuse
yeah
okay yeah that's abuse
and i'll go to the mat with anybody who
wants to tell me otherwise if you take a
child
and you take human contact away from
them and you hand them a screen
that's abuse
yeah full stop
if mother's um an addict
and he doesn't get the
prenatal care that he needs and he
doesn't especially get the
post like
post birth hey we're dealing with this
he's going to need some very direct care
because he was born an addict
um
that's abuse
you got it right so
um all that to say is this they don't
have just a willy-nilly right
because you know what he's three his
body knows
that with ann and his new dad
he's able to drop his shoulders for the
first time ever
he's able to engage and look at somebody
and what you're gonna have to do and
this is a common thing and i i'm not
putting you in this bucket this is for
everybody there's this idea that i'm
doing a good thing when i adopt or when
i foster i'm doing something good for
humanity
and because i'm doing that the cosmos is
gonna make this okay
it's gonna make this easier you know
what i mean and so i want to
give you like the reality check that you
already live which is you all chose to
adopt a three-year-old little boy who's
had lived in hell
and so it's gonna be
a chore it's going to be tough walking
alongside this little boy and teaching
his brain what safety looks like and
teaching him what connection looks like
and teaching him there's life outside of
a screen
all of those things are going to be a a
chore
it sounds like your husband is similar
to you that now his life is super
different and it's easy to just find
somebody to point rage at and i just
want to tell you don't do that it's a
waste of your life just don't
okay
here's the thing that i think going all
the way back to us about to say
a beautiful moment would be
you and your husband get a babysitter
and y'all go spend a half day together
you don't talk about the kids as much as
you talk about okay we got three now
what do we want our life to look like
what do we want this thing to look like
what do you need what do i need what do
we need
to be okay
so that we can go back in and do this
hard thing that we're doing
and this should be a moment of dreaming
not a moment of ranting and raving
yeah there may be some seasons of grief
like i wish we hadn't
that's okay to think that
you're not broken
it's okay to be really frustrated at
your stage of life right now
it's okay to really miss your husband
before he got angry and to really miss
man with just two little two newborns
y'all could just have sex whenever you
could go on dates when it y'all can do
whatever
and now you got a three-year-old on top
of everything and i just need to go to
the bat right all that
it's okay to grieve that we had this and
now we've got this
what you can't do is let all of that
external stuff roll off on this little
boy
that now calls you a mom
yeah and he's not broken he's got some
challenges no question about it be hard
and you know they'll have an open
adoption which i think is great in
almost every situation when there's not
abuse
and maybe grandma and granddad can come
around at some point um but you all get
to set the boundaries with mom and dad
the same way i set boundaries with my
parents and my in-laws you get to set
those with grandparents and other
parents this is how we do this our kid
doesn't ever look at screens ever period
full stop he's not allowed to look at
them so if you're gonna be around our
child that's just the way that's going
to work
our child doesn't eat these foods our
child goes to bed at 7 30 and not
midnight or what you know what i mean
whatever the thing is
um and i am going to marginalize
those
grandparents as much as is ethically
okay right as much as it's okay
not to punish them but to help heal this
little boy
yeah
does that make sense
yeah it that
that's
what feels right um on one hand but also
you know you're a mother
you know yeah you know yeah you're not a
babysitter you're a mom yeah
yeah and they do love him you know i
know they did love him
you don't have to protect them
they did the best they could i'm glad
they did i'm glad somebody in that
little boy's life stepped in and kept
him fed and sheltered
i'm so grateful for that and they kept
him safe good for them i'm glad they did
i wish they had different tools and they
didn't have them so great
yeah okay
um
now you guys got next level you got 2.0
little boy now we're going to teach them
how to live a whole and healthy and well
life
but a whole new healthy well-life for
your kids starts with you being whole
and healthy and well and your husband
being whole and healthy and well and
your marriage being whole and healthy
and well
and that all starts with us going out
and getting away from the madness
getting to a different location and
looking at each other and going
so we did a thing
now there's three and everything leveled
up as nate was saying earlier like
anyone i know who goes from two to three
like everything just changed
it it's not
we added 33 more busy we added a hundred
percent more busy um
and so now we gotta just adjust we might
need to get a babysitter that comes and
stays with us during the day we might
need to
get grandma on ground i mean parents to
come whatever the thing is what do we
need and then how are we gonna reverse
engineer that make that happen
keep doing the things
the one-on-one time the face
the the touching on the face touching on
the feet the hugs
the hand holds the going for walks keep
doing those things playing in water
playing in sand tactile things keep
doing those things with this little boy
it's going to be a tough road to hope to
hope no question about it keep going
so so grateful people like you are in in
this this in our communities
you are what make things better